all right on helpful advice with Bobby
kalila this is from Vito on Twitter
loved the podcasts question are you guys
believers in the belief / myth that you
don't really know a person until you
live with them oh I do believe that 100%
100% yeah I know
kalila a lot more now by living with her
one thing you would not have noted known
without living with her one thing out
there I mean human she eats a poop she's
she's a sensitive person yeah and she's
far more sensitive than I thought she
was she's very gentle and stuff she
needs hugs
she needs cuddles this is a complaint
and she's you know because when I first
dated I'm like wow this girl is like not
intimate not doesn't like the girly [ __ ]
like Rory Brody
the one thing that she does do that's a
little weird is you know how after sex
women want to like cuddle and you know
they want to go let's let's lean
together for an hour but she's the
opposite she's like get out or let's not
touch you know which I like I like that
I like that oh you're it I don't do that
I don't say get out no but you can just
tell there's I got you know there's a I
just you know I say I've read into this
I think I suffer from like a post-coital
depression while post-coital blues and I
think it happens with with some people
and I talked to AUSA about this and I
think I'm I'm some one of those people
that gets a little blue right after an
orgasm I don't feel that euphoric
feeling of the yeah let's tackle the
world because I had just got laid I feel
a little bit sad oh yeah
because I'm a man George just say she's
a man yeah I feel a little sad I don't
feel that you know rush of you know
endorphins I don't I don't feel the need
to intimately bond with Bobby I kind of
want to self-reflect
then cut my wrists well that took a dark
turn
yeah and so one thing you've learned
about Bobby's is living with him
although you can never tell just from a
parent alone I mean of course what's one
thing it's things that sticks out the
fact that he sleeps 16 hours a day but
he actually legitimately hibernates
that's cool that all of winter for three
months he doesn't really cause bears
it's a feature like yeah but I I think
that you don't know anyone until you've
shared a toilet with them and there are
friends that I've known for several
years for let's say 10 years and then I
go on a on a two-week vacation with and
I'm like wow I do not like this person
but I've known I've been friends with
him for 10 years but just in a confined
space I'm like I need to step away and
from this person forever well because
there's certain things that I'm like wow
like that's what you really do on your
chill time [ __ ] out of my face you know
anyways next question Gilbert there's
one more big one and we're done
the last one yes alright this is from
Zach I lost my virginity at 19 I'm 27
now to have left have slept with 50 to
60 women yeah killing the game Zach I
now have a great girlfriend in fact she
is the best girlfriend I've ever had in
almost all categories before we got
serious about dating we were on more
casual terms I got I could not get
enough of her every time we saw each
other we would be ripping each others
clothes off we've been living together
now for six months and I think something
is wrong with me I still have a sec a
strong sex drive but all I can think
about is other girls because of this we
only have sex about once a week I'm not
sure if I have troubled my outlook by
sleeping with so many people I'm not
sure if I could feel fulfilled and I'm
in my monogamous relationship I know
cloud and Bobbi both have likely have it
passed with ton of partners how have
they struggled with this it's I mean
it's one or the other it is it's in
human nature it's not something that I
made up but it's like um the other day
there's a doorman at the Seattle parlor
live he we were smoking outside I'm
smoking a cigarette and he goes so how
long you've been with your girl I go
three years he's like I've been married
for 16 years
kids and I go and he goes uh there's not
a date that doesn't go by they don't
think about other women but I love her
so much I love my kids so much that I'm
obviously loyal and and I'm in it for
the long haul and I said I feel the same
way bro yeah it's it's one of the other
and let me say something I've been in
situations where I was like God you know
I love this girl but I gotta get out and
I get out you know but this is the only
situation I've ever been in where I'm
like I want to stay in it for the long
haul but do you feel as though the long
haul necessarily means very very strict
monogamy because down the road let me
tell you something Bobby and we've
talked about this before
I am so understanding of human biology
and human desires so much so and I
respect it so much that if you were to
ever
I'm not disillusioned I I know that
every day you probably think about a
woman other than me and the same way
that in the same way that I probably
it's not just men women do too we
probably are less vocal about it but we
do like but what I'm saying is this road
of love this story that we create
doesn't have to be defined by such
strict rules of monogamy whoa dude what
are you saying
right now I would never I would never I
would never betray your trust I would
never do anything without you seeing it
in broad daylight what I'm saying is
down this road should you ever come up
to me and say hey you know what sweetie
this is what I had in mind and this is
what you know whatever we need to notice
no no crew supper sex nope nope I would
not why are you so because this is
exactly the road you went down with
g-unit and Danni Steve no I never that
was the first you're gonna hold me to
one meal I'm saying though I'm not
holding you to it but I'm saying that
these are the seeds that are being
planted for that kind of situation and
what I'm saying is is that I'm not gonna
do that what I'm saying is yes I do
maybe I'm projecting my own my own
fantasies yeah down the road I if you
wanted to have sex with me and another
woman I probably would be down with that
and I probably would orchestrate I would
probably planted something that I would
why because you think it's a gateway
drug and you're an addict like that you
think that one [ __ ] is gonna lead to
ten more but it's not if you just a
gateway drug I'll be shooting a heroin
[ __ ] no anyway well that's something
that we'll explore next podcast with
Chris Pataki what task is whatever his
name is
yeah chris wachowsky is uh somebody
that's on the show love with me and we
had a couple of scenes together a couple
weeks ago and I really really love the
guy cool guy he's a white dude from
Chicago very funny and I also say he's a
[ __ ] Slayer he's a Slayer I can tell ya
I can tell but um he really wants to do
tiger bellies so I said all right come
come onboard so that's what they'll be
next week and we'll talk about this next
week and I'm a little uh nervous right
now about tonight so focus is this I
just need to get not do this it's really
good to you know list let's do a moment
of silence for the people that passed
away in Orlando
is that appropriate I'm sorry
why you smiling Gilbert that's so
[ __ ] rude what your - stop stop the
moment of silence that's so [ __ ] rude
what you're doing right now doing your
smiling that's [ __ ] rude dude I'm
looking guys no no don't [ __ ] ever
smile again smiling at me during a
moment of silence look at Georgetown USA
look at him oh wow yeah that's [ __ ]
how you do it bro look anyway we'll see
you next week